guys i gotta say i love all kinds of
movies
and no shade to like spider-man or the
marvel movies or anything but this is
the most fun i've had watching the movie
in a long time
so you're saying it's better than
spider-man that's what i'm hearing
that's all we hear et canada just yeah
yeah yeah yeah studio 666 better can you
write that down for us
can we use that on the billboard can i
tweet that when we're done
that's going to be on the lower third
for every shot we do on our show
better than yeah got the headline yeah
whose
deranged brain did this all fall out of
where does this come from
well
so a friend of mine mentioned to me that
um
someone told him they'd love to make a
foo fighters horror film
and i thought that was the stupidest
thing i'd ever heard it was a terrible
idea there's no way we'd ever do it how
dumb why would we ever make a horror
film and then we moved into this creepy
old house to make our new record so the
house in the film we actually made our
new record in that house but while we
were in there writing and recording i'm
like wait a minute we're in this creepy
old we might as well just do it i mean
we're here we have the place
and so i came up with a really simple
idea that we move into a creepy house i
become possessed and kill everybody and
then it just sort of like snowballed
from there just ballooned into like now
there's screenwriters and now they're
special effects and now it's a
full-length feature film so it just kind
of kind of got away from us it really
did like oh my god we're making them
what are we doing right now why is there
so many cameras here we thought it would
be a couple cameras right i love it too
that it's it's medicine at midnight too
that was like like the happy party dance
record record and everyone dies yeah and
then i just murder everybody
yeah yeah still ironic or 90s
is it all like
was it a full script were you ad-libbing
a lot of it along the way there was a
full script written um
it was inevitable that we were going to
kind of like ad-lib or
go off script take after take after take
taylor hawkins
didn't read the script he just played
his best taylor hawkins which worked
amazing that's right
um but yeah i mean yourself
you can't write that stuff you know you
can't write that
you gotta be yourself he just kind of
writes himself yeah i mean
yeah there's some very successful actors
that have done that exact technique so
of course i've studied them
like i always say we don't call it
method acting we call it head
acting so who would you say that on e.t
we just did you just did you just did
lower third better than spider-man so
who would be the first head acting
to like ruin the take because they're
laughing like who's the first to break
when you guys were shooting this thing
i had a scene with whitney cummings and
i was just so nervous because she's more
of an actress and had her together
and uh
i was just that nervous kind of like
giggling and screwing up each take and
then i was like okay i'm now people are
waiting so i got it together
camera guy's giving me the stink guy
okay yeah let's not be cute yeah pat's
almost laughing and a lot of it you can
kind of see
yeah which he's kind of doing in real
life anyways so it's like it's kind of
like half like
so you know oscar nominations came out
this week
uh when you guys are
eventually called up onto the stage next
year for the academy awards like are you
johnson like is does everybody get an
opportunity to speak or is it just gonna
be one of you like how are you gonna
handle that speech
uh i think that we just disregard any of
that like walk-off music or whatever
they call it and each one of us
i mean listen this is our one chance at
the big time if we're gonna grab an
oscar for this one i'm not cutting my
speech for anybody grammy's not married
either i don't think you should either
oh no i don't think you should yeah just
one and done then
then you're finished with us they'll
never invite us back yeah but give us
our time just just give us our time yeah
beautiful guys thank you so much
thank you for agreeing to make the movie
first of all so that we can all enjoy it
and uh thanks for this time
thank you better than spiderman
spiderman
better than spiderman thanks buddy